in the face of growing outrage president
Trump is trying to disavow a racist
chant from his own supporters at a rally
in North Carolina CBS News has learned
the president's own family is part of
the reason for his decision Paula Reid
is at the White House Paula who was
involved in swaying the president oh
Anthony the president's rare show of
remorse came after pushback from his
wife and daughter he now says that he
feels badly about these chants this end
representative Ilhan omar back to
somalia he even suggests that he tried
to stop it but the video shows something
different I think I did I started
speaking very quickly and it really was
a loud I disagree with it by the way the
chants started after the president
attacked representative Omar Omar has a
history of launching vicious
anti-semitic screens and he let them
fill the arena for nearly 15 seconds
before moving on when she talked about
the evil Israel's I was not happy with
it I disagree with it but again I didn't
say CBS News has learned this show of
remorse came after the first lady and
his daughter Ivanka Trump voiced their
concerns and counseled the president to
moderate his position or at least
distance himself from the chanting the
rally came three days after the
president began his attack on the for
Congress women telling them to go back
to where they came from
sources reveal the president initially
had misgivings about appearing to
apologize or give in as it may
disappoint his supporters but eventually
he decided to relent a group of
congressional Republicans also
complained to Vice President Mike Pence
and asked him to speak with the
president which he did the president is
rarely moved by GOP discomfort which is
partly why Republicans continue to dodge
this issue in public I saw a clip the
president didn't join in any chant like
that but even the House chaplain weighed
in on this week's controversy as he
opened the houses session this has been
a difficult and contentious week in
which darker spirits seem to have been
at play in your most holy name I now
cast out all spirits of darkness from
this chamber it is notable that the
president changed his language after
hearing from a broad spectrum of voices
but any unfavorable reaction from his
supporters who so frequently say they
love that he never backs down could send
him back to his old tricks
Jericka Paulo Reid at the White House
thank you